hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another sundance 2022
interview with one of my absolute
favorites it's micah monroe hello
congratulations on watcher thank you so
much i'm happy to be here no one of my
favorites because we always get to talk
about fun genre projects we really do
you're keeping the trend going right now
and i appreciate it
so out of a festival there's probably
very few people out there who know what
watcher is so i have to ask you to do
this can you give us a synopsis of the
movie yes um
a young girl moves to romania with her
husband
um
and
you know she doesn't speak the language
she doesn't really fit in and um so she
starts spending a lot of time in
the apartment that they live in
and uh begins to notice someone watching
her
and as the story unfolds um
she becomes kind of obsessed with this
person watching her and then you kind of
begin to question who's watching who
it's very good very good so very very
sneaky descriptions happening there i
like it
so like i just brought up you do a whole
lot of horror and it is making me wonder
yes what drew you to the genre initially
and then what keeps you coming back for
more is there anything recently you've
discovered about what it feels like to
make a horror movie that you know maybe
scratch is an itch you didn't have at
the beginning
um okay well i i grew up uh
loving
uh old classic horror movies um
watching
uh nightmare on elm street and the
shining probably way too young
uh
but there was just something about it um
unlike other movies that you you always
have such a visceral reaction to the
genre that um was very intriguing to me
um
and then you know i ended up becoming an
actor and ended up doing a movie called
it follows um that
not to
you know
uh i don't know what it is gloat about
it but i think that film really kind of
changed
or was the beginning of the change of
the horror genre and and kind of going
back to
its original roots of like the shining
and and carpenter um
and so i think since that time there's
just been so many
incredible genre films coming out and so
many people involved with the genre so
for whatever reason
i um
i just keep coming back there's just you
know there's especially with this script
um
it was i just fell in love with it and
fell in love with the story and um
so yeah i'm so tempted to get up right
now and grab the gigantic it follows
poster that's literally right there but
then everyone looks in my sweatpants and
i can't ruin the match
another thing i really wanted to ask you
about was choosing you know studio films
or independent films because one of the
things that excites me about your work
the most is that i feel like almost your
entire filmography is you know smaller
projects that have the ability to be far
bolder and take more risks so you know
it's been it's been a little while since
the independence day resurgence release
and i guess also fifth wave so you know
since then why has it been especially
important for you to stay committed to
independent projects and i guess work
with a whole bunch of really exciting
emerging voices in the process
yeah i think um
i
there are positives to
uh studio films and and uh
a lot of great things that come with
that
um
but i guess
for me
i really want to keep loving my job and
love what i do
and
the way for me to
um
kind of keep falling in love with
this um
form of art is is working with people
that really inspire me and being a part
of the process
and the indie film world um
i i just i don't know i i'm just so
drawn to it and it's
it pushes me and challenges me in ways
and um
so yeah it's very fulfilling i guess
can very much understand that and i can
see it and sense it in your work
so speaking of exciting emerging voices
a first feature here for chloe so
what is something about her
her past work or anything she said to
you in your in your initial meetings
that made you think yup this is a
first-time feature director that i
should be taking a chance on yeah uh
well i had actually seen her
um
short film [ __ ]
uh
probably
six months before
um sorry about that
um
six months before
actually receiving her
um
her feature length script
and i um
have you seen the short
i have not seen this oh you have it's
it's incredible um okay it just is it's
so stylized and specific and
um
anyways so i i you know six months pass
and i'm sent in in an email i see
chloe's name
and um and just absolutely freak out i'm
like oh my god i hope that this script
is good because i i'm like dying to work
with her i think that she is
um pushing the boundaries
in ways that are very interesting and so
anyways um read the script can't put it
down and then we end up um talking on
zoom
and it was just like love at first sight
we just like hit it off and just
both had a very similar connection with
the
the script and the story and um
yeah it was it was a blast working with
him do you watch a lot of shorts in
general i i feel like more people out
there should and we don't talk about
that nearly yeah i think it's um
a really
um
i mean yeah i i think you can find a lot
of up-and-coming filmmakers through
um
shorts so yeah i i
sorry
it's only a matter of time before
something like that happens over here
um anyways yes i i really i love
watching shorts because it's um
i don't know i find like cool new voices
i love hearing that all right
specifically with your character in
watcher now so admittedly the movie does
not need this whatsoever but when i get
super into something i need to know
every single detail about the story and
about them so before jumping into
filming did you have to do any kind of
backstory work for the character
yourself like the specifics of like i
got very hung up on like why did she
leave her acting career behind what does
her family think about her moving to
romania things like that
um i mean you know chloe and i would sit
and we kind of
make up our own
backstory and and
what has been going on for the you know
for
her
life and her relationships and how they
affect the specific story at hand so so
yeah we we i think i got to romania
probably two weeks ahead and we just
hung out and kind of talked it talked it
out
where i was reading in the in the notes
that the story was originally set in new
york city where were you attached when
the film was set there no okay no but it
was i was chloe had told me that when we
first had met um
and i i mean now just because i've done
the film and read the script only taking
place in romania i can't really imagine
it being new york i don't think it would
work the same way
it wouldn't work the same way i just
imagine like it probably could have
worked but i think what we got
is probably
exponentially more intense because it
increases the isolation tenfold
definitely
yeah
speaking speaking of that so you filmed
on location in romania so how was it
working with that language barrier
because i've got to imagine yeah put you
in the character's headspace far faster
but it's gotta add challenges to the
process
uh definitely i mean it um i didn't
really know what to expect i didn't know
much about
um
romania or bucharest um
but i really fell in love with the city
it took time and again like it's always
uncomfortable initially in a country
especially when you don't speak the
language um
but we got to go to so many beautiful
locations filming i got to see so much
of the city and like the crew and
everyone was oh man like
so um
yeah it was it was a special place
is there anything about the production
process over there that's strikingly
different from the hollywood system
not really
i i didn't notice a huge difference um
i mean language there would be some
language barriers but you know nothing
we couldn't get through
how about working with this kind of
pacing because this is a very it's a
very atmospheric movie and it's got a
necessary you know slow burn feel to it
so for you what is the key to you know
getting into and then staying in the
right rhythm and also
you know being able to take your time
with certain moments because as someone
who's like go go go all the time i feel
like i would lose my patience and then
all of a sudden lose the rhythm and
start moving yeah definitely i mean i
think chloe was a huge part of that and
and
um
pacing is key in in a in a genre film i
think um
and that's something chloe is just
naturally gifted that and
um
but yeah i mean i i think uh
from the years that i've been
in this industry i think genre films are
probably one of the hardest
as an actor
um because every day is um
really tough on on you physically and
mentally
and this one was
no different
i asked this question a lot on my other
show ladies night and i'll pose it to
you because of what you just brought up
but looking back over all your other
horror films is there anything that
makes you think i am so glad that i did
that then that i at least tried it but i
would rather not do that ever again
um yeah i mean yes it's
i i've yeah there's been it's so funny
like when you read a script
even now and i've been i've i've read a
lot of scripts and i've done a lot of
movies but like i i still forget that
i'm like actually gonna physically have
to go through all these things
you just don't think about you're just
reading you're like oh man this is
awesome this is great and then you're
just like
you get outside you're like oh oh my oh
my god i'm gonna have to have to do this
was there any particular day on set
filming watcher that made like like a
day where when you looked at the the
schedule breakdown you kind of circled
that day in red and said that's gonna be
the hard day probably i mean can i am i
allowed to give stuff away where are we
at probably like very vaguely we don't
want to spoil anything uh well just say
yeah a lot of the the end of the film i
think we spent about three days kind of
shooting that last sequence
and uh
i knew that those days were going to be
tough
real tough
pays off though it's a very very very
effective build
so sorry this is honestly over the last
two years i don't even react to it it's
just kind of normal and right in this
space
you know how many times my cats like
knocked my computer over or
whatever
so yeah this is this is what we're
dealing with
this is burnt his virtual sun dance it's
got its own unique special charm to it
all right how about filming this during
covid so
i i feel like anyone probably knows this
about me at this point but i'm always
someone who is like desperately reaching
for silver lining so is there anything
about filming a movie with covid
protocols that like yeah put certain
restrictions on the process but because
of those restrictions you realize that
something is more important about that
process than you ever have before
i've never uh i've never thought of it
that way that's interesting
spreading the light
i like it um
i mean i i i don't know it was like
uh it was the first thing that that i
had um shot during um covid with all the
covet protocol and
i it's it's tough
it's tough um
just because i i'm sure as everyone says
just being on set is such a family
dynamic
and not that that is different but
you know you're supposed to keep six
feet apart and you don't see everyone's
faces i mean it was so hard for me to
remember everyone's name and like no or
or i don't know it was it was just it
was really tough and and
by the end it got easier
um
but uh
yeah i mean we were in romania i mean it
was like the height it was it was it was
tough
i can very much understand that finger
fingers cross for a light at the end of
the tunnel soon but respect to all of
you for powering through it and making
it work yeah
let's talk a little bit about some of
your co-stars here i love burn so much
oh i feel like he always deserves more
credit he does he gets man and he is so
good in this he's perfect
so
given the
[Music]
connection between your characters is it
one of those scenarios where you kind of
have to you know keep your distance and
maintain that type of relationship even
when the cameras aren't rolling
no we we were pretty um
he's a re like he's just too nice of a
guy to like be like scary to me
just like
uh just such a sweetheart so no but but
you know when we get close you'd see you
know put his headphones on and i'd give
him space
um
but yeah man he's so good in this he's
so good
what about just in general for you
especially given how many horror movies
you've done where you kind of like need
to keep your head in that zone what do
you do in between takes so
you know you can keep accessing that
kind of feeling but maybe not get
consumed by it yeah it's music for me i
always have my uh
headphones uh with me it's really the
only thing
uh
yeah it helps immensely
understandable what kind of music
really depends
like it depends on what i'm shooting
what's the feeling um but yeah so it's
all different i don't know i need some
recommendations any new favorites
um
gosh dad
like
i'm like who who do i listen to
like
this is gonna start not with this movie
but like tracy tracy chapman is like
i've listened
a lot while filming stuff not
necessarily this though just on the
watcher i don't think i did but anyways
yeah
it's always a good recommendation that i
will happily take yes
how about carl actually is it just a
coincidence that you two work together
on this movie and another movie back to
back it is somewhat coincidence um
we yeah we were shooting
watcher and then um
i knew that this next movie was coming
up and uh
they were trying to find someone for
this certain character in this other
film
and i just had to email the director i'm
like you know i'm working with this guy
carl like
he might be really good for this like
you should watch his stuff
and then they ended up meeting and
talking and like hit it off and i'm so
sorry
third time's a charm
it's okay i'm crying this has to be it
i'm just like what what is even down
there like what's happening
something very important you're gonna
have to follow up and let us know are
these all the same thing is this i'm
just like oh listen i i will let you
guys know i will let you know what
um
anyways uh so yeah
kind of so not really by chance but
anyways they they met hit it off and
then we went straight from romania to uh
mexico
it makes me so happy to hear that you
can connect the dots like that have you
ever done anything like that for someone
else in the past or the other way around
where someone's done it for you
i mean i don't think so i i don't think
i've ever worked with
someone back to back like this i'm
trying to think of i mean i've worked
with people
multiple times well really only
directors but yeah i i think this was
the first time and it was really nice
because you you have a
yeah a
a relationship already going into it so
it really helps immensely that other
movie looks nuts based on i did some
instagram stalking and i saw some some
images and that looks like it's full
project it's skin it's going to be crazy
it's like it's not a book right yes
based on a novel it's uh
wildly different so
oh okay
i feel like hearing it's wildly
different makes me want to read the book
even more so that then i can have two
somewhat different experiences in the
end
i kind of like that
all right i gotta let you go soon but to
wrap this all up here on watcher
big question what it what is a a tool in
your acting toolkit so to speak that
you're eager to apply to future projects
that you know you gained working on
watcher
oh man
maybe uh and i think i learned we talked
about this a little bit but from chloe
just like
pacing especially in a genre film like
having the ups and downs and taking your
time with certain things
um was really
really important on this film and i
think that i will take that on
um for future projects
i like that i feel like it's so easy to
undervalue like things like pacing and
taking your time and inserts in horror
movies you just want to do like the
money shots and get going but
money shots don't work without that
stuff that's true
all right i gotta let you go huge
congratulations thank you
i cannot wait for the next one yes
i'm greedy hurry up and give me more
movies
so good seeing you
you